[Music]
hey guys it's katie and you may not know
this about me but i love deviled eggs i
think my aunt marilyn makes the best in
the world but today i am testing out
four celebrity deviled eggs recipes and
i'm gonna have some taste testers along
the way and we're gonna find out which
recipe is the most excellent
the celebrities that will be facing off
today are kourtney kardashian joanna
gaines aina garten and oprah let's see
if i can keep up with kourtney
kardashian's recipe which is up first
the first step for this is just bringing
water up to a boil which we already have
here and then we're just gonna add in
we're gonna add in a dozen eggs
carefully there we go
i did not crack it maybe i should have
done these one at a time this is not a
great method to boiling eggs so far so
we're gonna let these sit for 10 minutes
then we're gonna drain them and let them
cool for about five minutes so next
we're gonna take our eggs and cut them
in half and then we will remove the yolk
and add that to a food processor
i'm team
not scott but i'm team travis but i am
i'm not team like the pda like making
out in front of her mom would you make
out in front of your mom
maybe maybe you would
the next thing is some himalayan salt
and we've got pepper
she adds some yellow mustard in and then
next she has you add some vegan
mayonnaise now this is obviously not a
vegan dish but maybe she's had vegan
mayonnaise before and just likes it
better than regular mayo what i'm most
excited for courtney's recipe is she
adds in a whole avocado and then the
zest of one whole lemon and then we are
going to
squeeze about two tablespoons
beautiful
nope nope
great
okay she's looking pretty good so next
thing we're gonna do is i'm gonna put
this into a piping bag and then we're
gonna pipe it into our eggs
oh cute
oh my gosh that looks
beautiful courtney so i will give it a
little chill time and then we'll have
our taste testers and we'll see what
they think
okay let's do it the color is a little
off-putting definitely these ones are
not the color that i would normally
think of when i think of deviled eggs um
the color is
odd to me
[Music]
it definitely is very like avocado
forward it's a little boring
oh wow
yeah i don't i don't really like this
sorry
our next recipe is from joanna gaines
we'll take a slice of bacon
dip your bacon in the brown sugar and
then flip it over these guys are gonna
go in the oven at 375 for about 14 to 16
minutes we will be right back so joanna
boils her eggs differently from courtney
she adds them into the pan before the
water which is something i would do
then she adds some vinegar and this is
supposed to make it easier to peel the
shell off the egg so we're gonna bring
this up to a boil then we're gonna turn
off the heat and let it stand for about
10 minutes all right our eggs have been
sitting for about 10 minutes let's take
them and put them in their water bath
which is going to also help shock their
shell and make it easier to peel we've
let the eggs sit for a minute and
they've cooled down so let's see how
easy or not they are to peel success i'm
gonna keep peeling all these shells and
we will be back to make the filling so
the next step in joanna's recipe is like
all the other recipes we'll see today
we're gonna cut our egg and then again
remove the yolk
so we're gonna add in some mustard
powder some fresh dill some chives dill
relish
some mayonnaise a quarter teaspoon of
salt i feel like this is gonna have a
big punch of flavor what i am gonna say
though is we're not gonna get that nice
super smooth look that we got with
courtney's unless i am spending like
days
mashing this joanna says you can take a
spoon and put the spoonful in or you can
take a ziploc bag fill it up and then
cut a little corners kind of making your
own piping bag we're gonna add some
paprika now we have our bacon that we
dipped in the sugar and then we baked
and i'm just gonna sprinkle a little bit
of that on top you can add a little dill
unless she says you can add some chives
we're done these are gorgeous i'm going
to cover this with some plastic and
we're going to let it chill for at least
one hour
and then we're going to see how they
taste let's do it
deviled eggs are like a loaded baked
potato but for eggs and that is what
this vibe is
okay
these look like winners to me already it
looks like there's bacon on them
which is cool
i really appreciate the dill in it give
me all the dill but i don't love
the sweet bacon i'm very into these
there's a lot of herbs maybe like a
little pickled action i'm not sure
these are amazing these are good these
are nice
maybe i'm not a big fan of deviled eggs
next up we have ina garten she's only
doing eight eggs they're extra large
eggs
so they're bigger but less of them so
we're gonna bring this up to a boil then
turn it off and cover it for about 15
minutes so our eggs are ready i've
drained them of the hot water and now
i'm going to be adding cold water on top
i think this is kind of similar to an
ice bath the cold water i think will
help shock these guys have been sitting
so let's see how easy they are to peel
whoa all right hey
this method is great and works well so
aina wants you to use a stand mixer
which is kind of like over the top but
let's see how it goes we're going to add
in some sour cream
a little bit of mayonnaise fresh lemon
juice some pepper salt she's serious
about her salt then we've got cream
cheese so she's definitely doing kind of
a play on like bagel and locks she's got
cream cheese and she's got salmon and
then we're gonna add in some chives
oh that's so beautiful
all the colors and then she wants you to
add a paddle attachment okay i think
it's pretty good
okay so she says to mix this until it's
fluffy so i get why she wanted to do the
standing mixer so you can kind of get
air in it and it won't be this like
dense dense thing you're adding to your
egg
um well let's see how it is
aina has you do the spoon method which
i've been afraid of this whole time but
we're gonna do it we're gonna spoon our
mixture into our eggs maybe it won't be
that hard i don't know why i'm afraid of
it okay okay why did i have so little
confidence in myself
we're gonna let these chill in the
fridge for about 30 minutes and then
we're going to garnish
aina wanted you to put these in the
fridge because she wanted the flavors to
meld together for a little while the
flavors have been melding now it's time
to garnish she has you add some salmon
roe on top which is fancy oh
my goodness
okay so our salmon is on it's beautiful
it's glowing and now we're gonna add
some chives on top
i'm loving this orange and green color
just getting so excited about eggs but
now let's get our taste testers in here
and see what they think
these are very extra oh
these are fancy girls these are so cute
that's delicious honestly all i can
taste is the row like it's
it's pretty fishy when that like salmon
row kind of explodes in your mouth it
just gives you like this rush of
salt i think it's really good though it
just reminds me of bagels our final
recipe of the day is from oprah
she doesn't say how to hard-boiled your
eggs she's just like hard-boiled eggs so
i'm not going to show you what i did but
i just basically hard-boiled eggs her
recipe i'm very excited about because
there's lots of dashes
uh as the measurements so i feel like
it's just like do what you like do what
you love feel it out which is very oprah
it's like you be you she likes sweet
pickle
i'm not a sweet pickle person i like
sour pickles but we're gonna see we've
got some mayo fresh squeezed lemon a
dash of it
that feels a little bit more than a dash
but
then she has you do a dash of
horseradish sauce
you do a dash
that's a lot and then she's going to
have you do a dash of worcestershire
i hope i'm doing this right oprah i'm
sorry and then she says one to two
dashes of tabasco i like a little spice
so happy this is going in this is the
only spicy one like horseradish and
tabasco is gonna clear up your sinuses
okay so one
two
three it was about three
and then she says a little bit of salt
and then a little bit of pepper
this next part in her recipe was a
little confusing she said
parsley two tablespoons she did she said
that we garnish with it but she also
like said it goes inside it's very
confusing so i'm just gonna put half of
the parsley in it and then garnish with
the rest
i like that her recipe was also written
like it was almost a spell it was like a
dash of this a dash of that
our mixture is complete oprah also spoon
method i have conquered my fear of this
after ina garten
i'm ready
there you go
gorgeous and then she tops with a little
paprika
at the end and then we're just going to
top with some parsley
oh my god she's gorgeous
let's get the taste testers in one last
time and then we're going to find out
who won this battle parsley has come to
the party this looks like a party it's
not going to be fancy it's not trying to
be like really gorgeous it's just like
i'm a deviled egg
this is like what i expect from a
deviled egg i think there's
worcestershire
it's a fun flavor mmm okay
i don't want the parsley i love the
pickles
[Music]
my favorite deviled egg was the one with
the row on top ina garden put the row on
top yes well that's in line with what i
said right i said either it was like a
pretentious celebrity or a well-trained
chef we love aina and all of her beach
vibes that makes sense delicious
my favorite i think was definitely the
the bacon one joanna games
oh
interesting very interesting okay i give
her a lot of credit that was a
an exciting and a very different take my
favorite deviled egg was definitely the
last one that was oprah's
that makes sense that's what i wanted
and she gave it to me
[Music]
i've taken the top three deviled eggs
and i'm gonna try them very quickly and
be the deciding vote so here we go
[Music]
now i'm going to try
aina's hmm
oh well i'm like the smoked salmon
thought i wasn't gonna like it
maybe i do
oprah
[Music]
wow
the horseradish like
that is singing through this
oprah wins it
hands down it's just like what you want
from a deviled egg good job oprah i feel
like all of these would be great if you
were for hosting any event
like they fit for different occasions
but i really feel like this one would be
a hit it just it's so good it packs so
much flavor it's got that acidity the
mustard
so good nice job okay okay well let us
know in the comments if there's any
other celebrity recipes you want us to
test out and we'll see you guys next
time bye
oh yes
you